uh and today's our last day of uh
boot camp and we are very very excited
to have
uh the expert on a cyber physical system
or as he will call them autonomous
systems so it's my pleasure to introduce
of option who is a professor at
university
of texas in austin so ufo is a very
prolific researcher if you would look
uh his publication record you will
probably feel
embarrassed and ashamed about your own
he's really publishing a lot of
interesting and exciting work
his research was widely uh public uh
recognized by various awards let me just
mention
an nsf career award of ieee
uh control system society antonio
roberti young researcher
prize which is which he just got last
year and uh
thank you very much ufo for agreeing to
give us this tutorial
and please uh the floor is yours or the
zoom is yours please
go ahead uh thank you so this is
recorded right
uh i can take this first couple of
minutes and show to my
parents and uh make them cry with your
introduction
that was an excellent introduction thank
you
uh the bar the the bar is high expert
and all that stuff let's see what
happens today
um so so this is i was telling to
zika that this is hopefully a casual
friday
you guys have learned a lot
and i am i am not qualified to teach you
on the formal what is this uh
fundamental foundations of computer
systems
uh because i i am just not
so what i am going to try to do is uh
tell you a little bit about
what kind of research that excites me
and also uh hopefully show you some
problems that
uh with a little bit of progress
and almost everything is wide open
um and um i
will have extremely sparse um citations
to people's
names and work and it is it doesn't mean
that
uh this is all what i know or i i have
done it is just i i have been lazy
uh whoever is interested in following up
on these things i will be more than
happy to
uh to give you as many pointers as you
like
uh so i was tasked with cyber physical
systems and
coincidentally last monday i had to
teach my first lecture for my
graduates verification and synthesis for
cyber physical systems course so i i
i figured i would get something from
that from those slides
um so and this is going to be a very
brief introduction hopefully
so this is i'm borrowing from reggie
valder's book
uh he defines cyber physical systems as
those that consist of a collection of
computing devices
interacting through communication with
one another exchanging information
and also i guess the defining part is
that the interaction with the physical
world
uh with sensors actuators or whatever
the whatever levels they have to
interact with the
physical world and there's a feedback
loop being closed
and and if you're going to look at what
is happening in
cyber physical systems you will find
lots of books and
one of the common features is probably
this convergence between control
communication and computation this is
what's happening usually in psychosis
and then i said all these people are
friends
i probably are missing some books and i
googled
cyberphysical systems and book and then
i came across this
uh so there is no end to this thing
it's don't worry it's going to end at
some point and these are just the books
that whose titles have actually cyber
physical systems in it
and there's an arrow i did not see the
end of this thing
it just rolls and rolls and rolls so it
is pretty established
field actually um and
there is quite a bit of similar flavor
in all these books that
they acknowledge this uh multiple
facets of the problem or systems and
uh then there is also that uh typically
unconventionally
uh these systems have been studied in
the intersection of
controls and formal methods and a little
bit of a
theoretical aspects of communication
perhaps uh this
is growing relatively fast
so then some properties of cyber
physical systems and this is where i
will transition to
in at the back of my mind i will use uh
things that relate to autonomous systems
as a running theme
so obviously this interaction with the
physical world and reactivity it is
an ongoing interaction it is it is
fitting the
usual definition of reactive systems
pretty nicely and then the physical
element is there
uh typically we built these things by uh
merging heterogeneous components and
they try to integrate functionality
and that that that creates
complex there and then the there are
other sources of complexity or
strictness of requirements that comes
from that
they operate in an open world and they
have to make the decisions
as they go on and the delays in
communication and computation can become
can become critical and then
you can take a system and put into a
bigger context like the
this picture i have at the
bottom right an autonomous vehicle
within an
infrastructure that also has automated
elements to it
information flow etc within the system
and
through the interactions of the system
with the broader context
uh concurrency can come in many
different ways
so these are just some of the properties
that
essentially make cyber physical systems
and autonomous systems very complicated
so one of the thing is that
many of these properties are what are
happening inside the system
and i think really what makes these
systems much more interesting is
and and now we have been studying these
kinds of properties for a long time not
that we have
we have succeeded in everything uh but
we need we are we need new problems
actually looking into the broader
context of what autonomous systems
will do how in what kind of environments
for what purposes we will use them
just brings up an endless amount of new
problems
and complications so obviously they will
be in dynamic environments
things will move around them we will not
be able to predict what they will be
doing
it is not just we put a system and just
it works there within its confined
environment
without interacting with the rest of the
world
and what they will do is not
over and over again doing the same thing
or a simple
going from a point to another point but
we want them typically
uh be able to deliver complicated
missions
i'm going to open a couple of things
here just bear with me
and in order to do all these things
again there is the heterogeneity and
decision
making and uh usually we deal with this
thing by
just building piece by piece and putting
them together and hoping that
when we put the decision-making elements
together table they will be
serving to what they are supposed to
serve and then
nothing runs forever without uh glitches
they will be subject to false and we
want to be able to deal with them
as they go on we cannot predict
everything every environment these will
be working in they will be deployed in
unknown environments
hence their complications
they will not be in isolation from
humans there will be human
users and humans will want to use these
things for different purposes
in different ways how they will be
interacting with
variations in the user characteristics
is giving
interesting problems i believe as well
they somehow need to
understand their worlds so they will
like with you they will need to pursue
what is happening around them and
be able to react to those things but uh
perception is never perfect
or we cannot see everything that we want
to see that's going to bring in
complications
and then as these things are deployed in
interesting environments
they will use data they will uh
they will be observed by others in the
world and we don't want them to
leak information
about their operation or about their
users in
unwarranted ways so that also brings in
uh
quite a bit of interesting uh problems
and we want to be able to do all these
things i usually put this
in the center the elephant in the room
is really verifiable
we want to play all these things and
then uh be able to
uh verify that these this will not harm
pose risks to people etc right so
verifiable is close to our heart and i
think it is at the center of what makes
autonomy interesting and hard as well
so in various forms so i'm going to
touch on uh
some of these aspects um but then let me
go on a little bit more so
we have a hard problem but we also are
we have been successful in various
fields right
uh it looks like ai is going to solve
everything i
i when i was preparing this talk i i
looked out there and
tried to see what ai can do these days
and one of the very nice articles was
that ai will be able to predict
when we will die that was the claim
i said that's great if ai can't do it
i'm sure it's going to be able to drive
my autonomous car as well
and then formal methods have been doing
uh things properly
for certain aspects of it and control
theory as well so it may feel like
everything is
solved but everybody brings in an
element to it and then also there are
limitations right
it may seem like you will be able to
learn everything and
obviously the fanatics of learning
seem to be claiming that very prominent
people but then
how are you going to verify that the
system is going to be safe and satisfy
all the properties that we care about
formal methods will jump in obviously
and say that
i know how to verify software surely i
can't do this but then there are
other complications that we don't have
precise models models adapt
things change over time etc and
autonomous systems are not just software
control may come in and say look within
some
maybe narrow context i have been dealing
with these things and
i have kept my airplanes safe
but on the other hand uh what
autonomous systems need to do is they
rather than what controls have been
dealing so long story short is that
autonomous systems are nobody's comfort
zone and we need hybrid solutions
okay this is this is the this is the um
this is the idea behind this talk and
here's a little outline
and i will keep an explicit emphasis on
that
a couple of things will interact to
solve
uh interesting problems for us um
and there are roughly four elements to
it one
first first for the first two i recorded
some
um some some presentations and posted
them on
on this on the institute's website
um so i'm not going to get too much into
details i will just try to give you the
flavors
and the first one is this correct by
construction synthesis of hierarchical
control protocols
and it's going to uh interactions
between formal methods and controls this
is
probably one of the areas out of the
ones that i will be discussing
that have been looked into for the
longest
and when my students ask me hey why we
are looking into these things i need to
have a fancy
question to them to motivate them so i
usually use this
question here when we try to program in
autonomous systems these days
for so that it does something and
usually it is in
in pretty naive environments it is a
very long trial and error it just
probably usually takes
months to do that maybe weeks and the
question is
if we face with a new mission with a new
vehicle how can we do these things in
one hour
rather than weeks or months that's the
if you can automate certain steps maybe
we can't do it
um and then the next piece is going to
be the interaction between formal
methods and learning and
for thoughts on verifiability and
reinforcement learning
and that is going to be motivated by
this question how can an autonomous
systems
system learn how to execute a new
mission in an
a priory unknown environment and i want
to emphasize that
efficiently and safely no autonomous
system will have billions of trials
and no autonomous system will be able to
tolerate
going and crashing tens of thousands of
times on the streets and figure out from
that so
we need to keep an eye on those
properties and
the last question is how we cope with
imperfections and limitations in runtime
information
and i had not recorded anything on this
so i will spend a little bit more time
on it just planning and
typically partially observing market
decision processes
and i'm gonna i'm gonna touch on two
different ways of
uh approaching these things that we
haven't looking into this is
one connection is between formulas and
comics optimization and the other one is
going to be foreign learning
okay so i'm going to dive into the first
one uh and
please please interrupt me i cannot
speak for two hours
i i can but it is not enjoyable uh so
so maybe uh just like a couple of uh
logistics
so baby would it be possible to after an
hour to make
a short five minute break that people
can grab a coffee and uh
need thank you and everyone if you post
the
i will monitor the chat if you have any
questions just please post then i will
then uh uh for tell or [ __ ] about your
question
thank you okay so let's dive into this
first one
uh it's pretty dated uh and
so this is a little bit of a like um
representative problem statement in cost
obviously there is no actionable problem
statement here
so given a system model and
specifications in some language
so the system model is going to have
both discrete elements
and differential equations or difference
equations or whatever
uh to describe how the system evolves
it can be richer typically captured as a
hybrid system model
and uh obviously the system is going to
have actuation limitations
and we will be subject to disturbances
and uncertainties
uh and then the another element is this
specification element which is extremely
central and we want to be able to
encode what the what a user might want
to do
our knowledge about the environment
perhaps even and then the regulations or
constraints that the system has to
satisfy and another element is that
we haven't i have an emphasizing that is
an open world we will be interacting
with
lots of other things around us so we
need to somehow
restrict the environment in which the
system is to operate
otherwise there is not going to be a
controller that will achieve the
requirements or the goals that we want
to have
if they think that the system might be
subject to all sorts of craziness that
is not realistic
and we want to be able to automatically
synthesize a control protocol that
manages the behavior of a system that we
are interested in
it's going to react to the changes in
the allowable external environments
and we want to be able to have an
argument that the outcome is going to
satisfy
what we wanted to satisfy at the end um
so uh
i will definitely skip the next slide
which is a ditcher for specifying
behavior with temporal logic
i'm not here to teach you temporal logic
uh but uh i want to say that
some
creativity has has gone into in
multiple fields in robotics autonomy
cyber physical systems whatever you call
all of them that temporal logic has been
a pretty um expressive um
language for us to go and uh specify
behaviors
for these systems but all safe allowable
required or desired behavior of
autonomous systems
so the this the details are not that
are not going to become relevant so
let's not get into the details but
in some form or others there's going to
be a relation to
variance of temporal logic as
specification language in
almost all pieces that we will be
looking into
and going back um sorry
going back this is a hard problem
because it has pretty rich dynamics
and also relatively rich
specifications so the solution is
never going to be a one shots uh
one hey here's something go and take it
and
that that's your solution right it's
going to have
uh multiple elements so typically it is
going to be a hierarchical
structure the names of these boxes are
not important
but it's going to have multiple levels
to it and
the connection is that each layer is
going to
deal with a different version of the
models
and then it is going to try to
address the relevant parts of the
specifications
so it's going to decompose the problem
uh in one way or other
and this is this is perfect fine uh and
nice because in engineering we already
do things things like this we decompose
problems
into smaller pieces that we can deal
with
um and then let me just say a couple of
things
as we go higher in the hierarchy here
obviously the models will become coarser
and as we go higher the uh
the scope of specifications is getting
broader
when we have continuous dynamics that
capture the physics of the system
we probably only want to deal with the
constraints on the continued state and
inputs
and as we go higher we might want to
look around us a little bit more and as
we go higher even further
the example that i typically use here is
if it's a driving example
the top layer might choose the highways
or the streets that you want to follow
and the middle layer now i know i'm
going to drive on the streets
whether there are cars around me whether
the lanes are blocked whether the
intersection is
empty etc stuff like that so that you
react to those changes
and once you decide that you have to go
to the left lane
then the top bottom level is layer is
going to find
a path that respects the limitations due
to the physics of the problem
and um and and find the path that's
going to do that
and depending on uh what's model
and what specifications that you are
dealing with
obviously the problem that you will need
to solve is going to change its form
um and this is just some representative
uh problems that
might make sense typically a uh finite
rising optimal control is at the bottom
uh if you have dynamic environments
in your model for this middle layer
um you may end up solving a two-player
turn-based game
on if you end up having a finite state
model
on a finite graph that i believe
we got lectured on a couple of days ago
and then uh and so on and so forth
so the point here is though uh anybody
can decompose any problem into as many
pieces as you like
there's there's no limitation to that
you need to be able to do it in such a
way that
once you put all these parts together
you have a solution to the problem that
you started from right
and that usually relies on uh the
consistency between the models that we
use for each layer
all right and the consistency means
if this layer for example tells to go to
the left lane
the bottom level should be able to find
that way to go to the left lane
all right and that means when we create
the abstraction
for the middle level here we should not
include the possible discrete directives
that may not be able to the bottom layer
cannot be able to implement
and that's the consistency between the
layers and obviously that consistency is
kept tracked through
simulation relations
and how you can come up with
abstractions
for each layer so that there's you
maintain that consistency is
what has gone into quite a bit of
research in this field
and um there are some ideas
uh that for each layer you might have to
bring in and ask yourself how i can
maintain a simulation relation
between these different layers depending
on
what what model representations you use
in each layer and what specifications
that obviously you want to
be able to keep consistent
across the layers i'm going to now dive
into let's zoom into a little bit of a
piece of
part of these bottom two levels just to
give you a little bit of a
an idea what might go into that so
bottom level is
um let's say we deal with a
difference equation discrete time but
continuous state models
and this is the workspace that we have x
is the workspace
and then it usually goes along the lines
of
we discretize the space into finitely
many cells and
associate a discrete state for each of
those cells
the labels of those cells and the next
thing that you want to do is
decide whether i should include this
transition from a discrete state to
another discrete states
and in order able to keep consistency
one way is
you go and ask questions like no matter
where i start
in this cell whether there is an
admissible control signal that's going
to take me
to this cell somewhere in the cell and
so more precisely
a little bit more precisely stated here
whether there exists a control signal
and some finite time such that
for all times between the initial time
and the final time
i stay inside the union of these two
cells
and at the end of the time interval i am
in where i am trying to go
i e this cell somewhere in that i just
want to be in that
and i want to be able to do it in such a
way that this holds for
all initial states so the quantifier on
this
starting point is for all and uh
quantifier for the final target set is
there exists
and i want if there are disturbances on
the dynamics we want to be able to
robustify against all possible
disturbances
and if somehow this brutal test is
passed we go and include this transition
okay because i know if i ever come to
the
uh cell that corresponds to this
new five here there is a way for me to
go to
the cell that corresponds to new time
and then
you're filling that by asking all these
pairwise questions
then based on this abstraction that you
have here you might solve a
reactive synthesis problem
that we looked into and let's say now
the outcome of the reactive synthesis
problem is this
uh discrete sequence that
the meaning of that is if you follow
that discrete sequence we will satisfy
the specifications that we have
then because of the way that we
constructed these
these transitions between the discrete
states
we will know that there exists a
continuous trajectory
that's going to take that's going to
ensure that we follow this high level
discrete sequence of states
and then that's going to give you the
that the fact that even the continuous
implementation
if you monitor it in a in a proper
manner it's going to satisfy the
specifications
and this is usually referred to as
correct by construction and the
construction part is this construction
of the abstractions that you use for
each layer
and the correct is that now i am correct
with respect to the specifications
and the procedure is brutally
and in a brute force manner constructive
that you ask
zillions of questions of this form
um for pairs of cells here
and try to answer them um
so good good and bad news here
if we could do it now we have finite
state representations a lot of things
that we know from formal methods we can
go and use them good but the bad news is
that
uh probably there are two three
different
disciplines that try to solve problems
like this by itself so
that it is not an easy problem
necessarily
um but then after all there are no easy
solutions for heart problems we just
change the nature and look of the
difficulties
and then over time people have
realized that some some of these
problems can be solved in
maybe a little more efficiently and
systematically than others
if the dynamics are linear we have some
hope
and for certain types of non-linear
dynamics maybe through approximations
uh we can't solve it so but there's a
there's a
there's a connection from here to um
approximately approximate simulation
relations etc
uh so let me show you
just a little bit of a you take a sip of
your coffee not
and if you're in europe maybe vine so
here's the um little example um
so this is a quadrotor that we will be
controlling
and these two will be quadrotors that we
don't control
they are controlled by someone they
don't fly themselves but the
the the controlled quadrotor does not
know how they will be behaving
and the specification for this
controlled quadrotor is going to be
visiting this point and i'm making it up
i don't know exact points this point and
this point
repeatedly something like that
so that could be post office i know
bakery and whatever that it wants to go
every day
and uh these are the bad guys we don't
know how they will be behaving
but we have this prior knowledge that's
hard
as part of the environment this
quadrotor is after all
a physical object if at one moment i see
it here
at the other next moment it's not going
to jump up and
uh like appear here it is it is going to
be
along this line this moves along this
line it moves these are the police
patrols they they just do that okay uh
and they they respect some sort of
physical constraints on their behavior
so uh and then we applied this
hierarchical strategy that i mentioned
at each time step now i cannot keep
track of the controlled one
uh but this is it is on the one on the
left
um essentially it sees the world um
and then uh tries to make a decision
where to go and
uh it is not that it always avoids the
uh patrolling
bad guys let's say uh but it tries to
strategize hey i need to wait now and
then okay all of them are on that side
now i can probably go through
um etc and um
it's it it does what it was promised
there
you can obviously see that there's some
turn taking
in this in this implementation uh they
it sees what is happening and then
takes its turn uh and um
nobody promised that there's not going
to be a turn taking because after all we
try to come up with this behavior by
solving a two-player
turn-based game right and
even from here you can we can now come
up with zillions of further
uh complications of all this business
that's
how to not do it in in such an explicit
term taking manners
and and we can we can discuss them
separately i'm not going to get into
these things
okay so this is the end of it this is
the first part controls
and formal methods have interacted
to solve a synthesis problem neither of
them
was accustomed to soul or even able to
solve
because one side did not want to play
with continued state dynamics and the
other side was
oblivious to rich behavior
specifications
and when they work together they have
been able to do something
so any may i uh
offer any any clarification at this
point
just so that i can drink some water
no questions right now you promised me
questions uh earlier just let me just
remind you
uh hopefully you will ask and help me a
little bit
okay so i'm gonna go now the next piece
the very verifiable reinforcement
learning
uh why am i even discussing this um
there are i think a good number of
reasons that
um we cannot close our eyes to learning
and i'm gonna try to
show one good reason and then a couple
of bad reasons later
um not bad reasons but uh i'm skeptical
uh so everything that this field i
described
did over one or a little bit longer with
one
decade or longer i'm going to put now in
this very nice
synthesis box and let's look at what
um what has been done there what has
been done is some
environment description some
requirements some maybe even performance
criterion is given
and we come up with this f and f in this
case may refer to this hierarchical
structure it's not just some function f
so a very very central
um assumption is that
we already know the the environment
description the specifications are
nice everything is nice just
very precisely given which is good uh
i am not against precision uh but
in reality uh we
will we will lack such uh sharp
descriptions of what we need to do so
one of the things is that we may not
know exactly what the environment looks
like
but we may interact with the environment
offline or online
so that's a reason maybe
uh learning could help us um
then we give uh very nice descriptions
of temporal logic specifications and
performance criteria etc
and uh in my experience only cs
professors
and some group of grad students can
speak temporal logic as their second
language
and uh usually the normal users cannot
do it
and but we want people to be able to use
it so uh
there is that mismatch between
what our tools can take and what normal
users can express
which is fine this is not a criticism to
anything formal
this is just a pointing to a gap okay
and uh and then we live in a world where
even if we actually go and isolate
ourselves from the rest of the world
maybe somebody's gonna come and knock on
our door and say ai has done this ai is
going to know when you will die for
example
so we cannot stay away from learnings if
you are developing an autonomous system
even if you say no i'm not going to use
any learning base anything
somebody's going to come bring a module
something into it or you will need to
interact with it right so
you might get information from outside
that relies on
some sort of learning so we can make
this list longer but
after long debate with myself that i
was convinced that we should look into
problems that are in the intersection of
learning and synthesis and in the
recorded uh
pre-recorded videos i
gave a little bit more historical view
on how these things had evolved in my
minds
the initial point was i did not know
what
learning was one of my postdocs brought
me a paper by
uh leicester violence and
he talks about uh probably approximately
correct learning and i thought okay this
this
this looks pretty pretty precise maybe
we can
take what is in there and then try to
insert some
uh formal methods of thoughts into this
uh for example temporal logic
constraints
how we can learn uh behavior that is
constrained by temporal logic etc
and uh and i'm not gonna get into those
i'm just gonna give you a couple of
glimpse of
different things that we have done for
example um for safety and efficiency
purposes
and reinforcement learning serves as
reinforcement learning serves as
a problem description that we can take
and
look into how we can we can maybe do
things slightly differently
and for here's a one minute crash course
on reinforcement learning
uh there is an agent it does not know
certain things about an environment or
about what it needs to do
it takes up some actions they are
implemented in the environment things
change
the agent needs gets to observe and
maybe somebody
comes and starts giving thumbs up or
thumbs down on hey
do it this way or not this way
and it can it can it can make pancakes
it can play board games it can fly
quadrotors everything is nice but also
it can
create behavior like this this is a i
believe a reinforcement learning
training agent
that bought and uh even though it might
be fun to be on that
we probably don't want to do things as
the sport does
uh so uh then we said let's put a new
piece of problem data
as a temporal logic specification and a
this specification in this context is
going to play a couple of roles that i'm
going to
mention but as its usual
reference we can ask whether a learned
strategy is going to satisfy the
specifications
or a more interesting problem is whether
during learning
we can ensure that we never violate the
specifications or at least some
safety fragments of the specifications
another way of specifications may come
into learning i believe is that
they are very nice representations of
knowledge that we can feed into
algorithm developments
hence if we have prior knowledge
that we don't necessarily relearn over
and over and over again
we may be able to encapsulate knowledge
in the form of temporal logic
specifications and see how it actually
can be
uh integrated into learning
uh to make it more efficient and then
there is the
uh there is a flip side of the coin this
notion of universal reinforcement
learning
uh there is a question about uh
synthesis and learning from maria
palomaria politics shall i just read it
do you want to state it loud
uh okay let me then just read it what is
the reward structure
in conventional synthesis and in
synthesis plus learning respectively
uh what is the reward structure i'm not
sure if
um i can give a precise answer to that
but uh in conventional synthesis
in reactive synthesis that i touched on
and probably the parts of the week that
we have looked into three-player games i
don't think that we had a reward
structure
per se right it was only
a the winning conditions were whether
you satisfy a temple logic specification
or not
but after all these things generate
behavior over
some uh over some state space
and they do they visit certain places so
you can
easily put a reward structure as a
function of the states
as a function of the states and actions
or whatever you want whatever
the right thing is and form uh form
these
games that we looked into this week but
some objective
on hey do these things in such a way
that you satisfy the specifications
while maximizing minimizing some reward
etc and it is the same thing i think in
reinforcement learning over
finite state spaces it is just
a function over uh
over the whatever you care it could be
states it could be
i don't know even sequences of states
maybe over what you see
the observations or actions might cost
you something
uh essentially it is a map from let's
say for simplicity from from
from the states to some drills
does it answer the question because it
was asking about the structure and i
don't know if i answered the structure
um yes thank you well the
the question was related to slide number
13 because
since there was the line known fixed
temporal logic constraints plus reward
structure
and the conventional synthesis the point
about
known fixed temporal logic constraints
was very clear but then there was this
line about having a reward structure in
conventional synthesis
and i didn't know what you meant there
and and i was kind of expecting
just like there was a comparison between
the two kinds of synthesis
um about the temporal logic parts i was
expecting a comparison
also for the world structure and that
didn't come so i had
i had like a question there but now it
is better thank you
okay um so i did not think about that
deeply
i just throw it in because some part of
the world
loves rewards conventional reactive
synthesis
i don't know what conventional reactive
synthesis means but uh
reactive synthesis by itself does not
necessarily have a reward
or reward structured but i i think
we can naturally define put a reward
structure
you can put anything on anything that
you like whether you it's
going to be a problem that you can solve
is a different question
uh so uh let me just say that much
reaction synthesis doesn't necessarily
perhaps have rewards but
there are versions of those problems
that we can introduce rewards and try to
attack to also
say that uh maria paula we will have uh
in the synthesis workshop
we will have a tutorial on reactive
synthesis where i guess
uh maybe the speaker will go more into
details about rewards and
things so ben will be the speaker on
reactive synthesis
but maybe uh mario paul does this answer
your question or uh
does we have more yes thank you and also
thank you for the further pointers
to other material thank you
thank you thank you and um one more
question from anna anna do you want to
unmute yourself or shall i read it
yeah i i had that can i i
seconded mario powell's question i also
had a question about that but i guess
it's now resolved
it's just uh for me this conventional
synthesis doesn't really
guarantee performance and that's why i
was also questioning this
but i i had a different question um
the different question would be so we
have let's say a specification
that we want to satisfy during learning
when we are learning something
like you started talking about this and
does it guarantee
that when we deploy the learned system
this
the specification will be satisfied
uh excellent question uh
you can ask that question right i don't
know how to answer it
uh what i can tell you that um
hard to discuss because there are so
many moving pieces
but at least if you're
deploying in the environments that in
which you trained
you want to be able to satisfy the
specification right if
if at least you don't satisfy that
you probably haven't done enough um
i it would be nice to be able to deploy
in
you know what i'm going to say but i
cannot say it because i don't know how
to even
discuss it but somewhat different
environments
and a couple of levels
hope that things not will not break
otherwise
what would be even nicer is that you
somehow predicts
if you can characterize give a
characterization of what kind of
variations in the environment might be
viable you want to be able to predict
how bad things will go
i believe
[Music]
after training prediction parties
if you can give a characterization of
the
new environments that's that we can we
can probably
give answers to that
learning in such a way that um
learning in such a way that you will
naturally be
nice in new environments i don't know
just actually
probably after this call i'm gonna
discuss three relevant problems with my
students
i think this is whack open i was
actually surprised we did
i'll come to that later but let me just
comment on that now
we did a couple of a little bit of work
on inverse reinforcement learning
where we incorporated temporal logic
specifications
as uh as
as side information that says that
everything in this world is going to
happen
in the way that this temporal logic
specification describes
and i was very naively hoping that
that would give us a little bit of
non-brilliance for environment changes
but i was utterly wrong so here's a
little
very tiny examples you have two rooms
and there's a wall in between them and
there's a door
and you see demonstrations that things
go through the
door and from that and you incorporate
that
you go through the door um
you learn something and in the if you go
and deploy the system in the
in the environment that you trained
everything works beautifully
you satisfy your specifications things
are nice etcetera
even the tiniest change where the door
is like move the door a little bit along
the wall you know there is a wall there
wall hasn't changed
door tiny bit moves uh
things break pretty badly so um
i was hoping that this high-level
knowledge that we incorporate
um would actually help in that
but what is not happening is the
following
the knowledge that we incorporate is
unfortunately about the
look it refers to the location of the
door
rather than that there is a door
so i think we are just i'm just jumping
ahead
let's go on but we can discuss and
changing environments
is is viewed okay i'll
i'll comment on that back again there
are some things that
specifications help but then some things
that not yet
okay so the first element is safe safety
by via shielding okay this is obviously
going back to
uh the work that uh roderick bloms group
had
initiated and they they they also are
part of this
so this is the conventional
reinforcement learning cycle and what we
will do is we will introduce this
runtime shield here it's gonna have
access to the actions
and it's gonna it can't it may see what
the learner sees
it's going to be able to modify the
actions
of the slurs so a couple of uh like
properties here
we wanted to be corrected the shield to
be corrected with respect to safety part
of the specifications
so no safety violation and
uh that since the
shield can modify the actions you can
actually pretty trivially do this thing
if you don't allow the learner implement
anything
can you if you can change everything
this learner tries to do then you can
you can do
obviously that's not useful we want the
shield to be minimally interfering
and and it is going the shield is going
to be
uh synthesized from a high-level
uh course abstraction of the environment
and
that is sufficient to interpret the
safety part of the specifications
and only that it's not going to refer to
the inner workings of the learners
hence it is going to be actually
agnostic to the to what the learner
how the learner was being so it was
therefore it can work with
google learning algorithms including
that use neural networks as their
function approximation uh
representation and and and possibly even
over continue state spaces so the
learner might be acting over a continued
state space
but the shield has a neat course high
level discrete
view of the world and if the learner has
some
desirable properties like convergence we
want the
shields to not mess up with that and it
is not going to be able to converge what
the
unshielded nominal learner merges to
because that behavior may not even be
acceptable with respect to safety
specifications
but we want it to be converging to at
least
constrained uh optimal solutions
so to some extent we were there are ways
to improve these properties that you if
you build the shield in the right
in an appropriate manner and then there
are these
empirical uh observations that we made
that it may actually help with the
learning performance as well this is
totally empirical and
case by case and the shield synthesis
itself is
it takes a course representation of the
world and it takes a safety
specification
and it comes up with a monitor it just
solves a couple of different
uh games essentially over finite graphs
all right uh so uh
and um and hopefully that reactive
synthesis
uh workshop could give more details on
uh
how these shields can be computed uh
so uh nevertheless though so
you first come up with some a couple of
elements that
monitor whether you violate it how much
you might be violating what the reasons
for violation are
and then it uses that information and it
comes up with a
permissive strategy to satisfy the
safety specifications
and out of the all possible ways of
correcting with respect to safety
specifications
you choose one that actually corrects in
the fastest way and delegates back the
back to the um back to the learner
as quickly as possible and that relies
on a book again
and uh and so
this is a little bit story behind this
when we tried to do these things
we said let's pick a trivial example
first
okay uh so that we can check whether
this stuff is going to work
and i thought a car
trying to drive around a circuit like
this would be a trigger example because
if you go to youtube you will find
zillions of examples of presumably
things are being learned in this way and
the cars go around circuits
and then we started implementing these
things
then i say v i usually mean a poor
student
uh started to implement these things and
the plain reinforcement learning act
part of it did not work
and then he started coming hey i need to
optimize this
parameter optimization or hyperparameter
optimization
so there is a thing called hyper
parameter optimization by the way if
anybody wants we can discuss that later
over
uh sufficient amount of y uh so
um it did not work and then bunch of
hyper primary optimizations
we got the reinforcement learning
without shielding working
and essentially this the uh sorry
the left side is non-shielded at the
right side is shielded
it is just all over the place here it
tries a couple of things it crashes and
it comes and restarts as the
reinforcement learning algorithms do
it it has pretty hard time in creating
an illegible behavior here
and it crashes uh zillions of times
the version of shielding actually
figures out a way to
complete this task uh much shorter
training
and with no crashes and the no crashes
is actually not it is only not
a property that we like but also it
enables that you learn a little bit
quite a bit faster the reason is that if
you don't crash
you don't have to go and reset this so
it's
it does certain things in in in randomly
but it continues to at least inch by
inch make
progress toward by chance seeing a full
circuit and
if it sees it it gets a reward and it
understands that okay this is this is
nice i should be doing this
so no crash essentially increases
likelihood of actually
getting some reward from the from
whoever rewards you
this one is scratches resets crashes
resets crashes resets
it is delayed for it to see any reward
so
it takes much longer to figure out what
am i doing in this world
okay and uh and then there are some
other cases that uh small
pac-man environments the shielded
version nails it plays better than i can
not another high bar anyway and then
other people have been able to work to
do these things over much larger pac-man
environments with
uh with its ghosts uh multiple ghosts
and etc
and the reason is again the one on the
right is never eaten hence it figures
out how to play this thing much faster
uh okay so that is that the next
question
so this is the safety part just one
example on how formal methods can help
us
try to keep some safety yeah oh [ __ ]
rainer posted her promised question i
never want to
unmute or shall i read it yeah i cannot
mute because i mean i wrote it just
shortly
so what i wanted to ask is about them
like for to synthesize the shield you
need
some abstract model of the environment
right and then in different situations
that
that needs to be more or less precise
depending on
and of what your environment is right
and what is the the problem so it's not
kind of yeah uh
i cannot tell you what exactly the uh
model here is in this example i just
don't know
because i mean i cannot i can imagine
that one can
kind of obstruct a model of the
environment and then
like that is sufficient uh to to
guarantee that uh
that the car doesn't crash but if it's a
real car right it's like
it shifts the problem to uh like you
know like how do you guarantee safety of
a real car you know
in a real kind of urban traffic right
and then it's not uh
yeah uh just totally we have been
pushing it under the rug and uh again
a heart problem is is not gonna become
easier yeah but what i can tell you is
that
like if you say um
and if if there is an mdp
large maybe even continuous state mdp
uh the way that i have been thinking
about this and
keeping myself a little bit happy about
these kinds of results is that
uh knowing precisely
what state you are at is very likely not
necessary for you to reason
whether you will be able to stay safe or
not so you can
you can abstract out the uh precision of
the state representation
and you may also actually work
instead of working with precise
understanding of the
transition probabilities you can you may
be fine with
some existence of transitions and the
structure of the mdp but rather than the
transition probabilities uh
and and and if in this case
the if the safety is implemented as
merely
um crashing on the wall
a representation could as well be
whether you are
close to the wall and whether you are
going toward the walls
right it could be as simple as that it
depends on
what safety specification at what level
that has been
specified and what how can you
have a dynamic model that is going to
help you reason about
the behavior with respect to that
specification
i guess it boils down to identifying
problems that are
properly decomposable in that way that
for safety you really need a lot less
information
than from the environment and for
guaranteeing the performance and
essentially decoupling the the two
and uh kind of getting the best of both
worlds
getting something from the board for us
uh hard to claim that you get the best
out of
both worlds but you look at the both
words
okay so the next question is
if there are similarities between the
two tasks
that's okay just let me just step back
you have two tasks
okay and in the sense that
there is an environment
and there are these regions of interest
and in both environments their shape
location etc are different uh
this person who actually looked into
this problem likes um
timed uh logic then
more than non-time so there are clocks
and with respect to these clocks you go
and write some specifications
uh no you don't write specifications
sorry
so let me step back we have these two
environments there is some underlying
task
that might have some time time related
elements as well
so uh we want to learn how to
execute this thing
[Music]
and so the the
premise here is that if you brutally
take
uh the pain in one environment for
learning whether we can
leverage uh that effort
and what we had uh figured out to
expedite
learning in a different but related
environment
for a different related task okay so
do your com usual learning here however
hard it is
then see if you can expedite this size
and if the flow is the following so for
for both you
collect some data and then
you try to infer what formulas might
explain what you are seeing in this
world
and then there is a relatively precise
notion of a logical similarity between
these two
if you declare that these two formulas
are similar to each other
then whether we can do something with
that all right so this one goes
all the way to learning and you learn
whatever you learn
and now we will ask whether we can
expedite this
reinforcement learning part of it based
on that
we discovered there is a logical
similarity between the
two the two tasks so i'm going to copy
these two pictures
in the next page and i'm going to show
you four results here
um one is that uh this uh
the learning method the so-called q
learning which essentially goes and
figures out and keeps track of what what
the rewards are except from based on
that
tries to come up that tries to come up
with
a policy so the black one
shows the the optimal behavior is
collecting
uh 100 rewards
uh the black one it shows this plane
learning and it just
starts tries to do a couple of things
and it then starts going up but then it
levels out
and we run this thing for fifty thousand
steps but you can run
two million steps five million steps
whatever this
continues to improve slowly but never
even gets close to
the optimal vehicle level then uh
what we do in this target environment is
first of all
start now incorporating the
specification that we had found
essentially now learning is over some
appropriate
a product space and then we
the there are multiple ways of inferring
these specifications with different
uh different cost functions
so this pink one shows the learning
behavior with
this temporal logic specification
incorporated metric interval temporal
logic specification incorporated
and this the specification had been
inferred using
uh one of the criteria for
judging that the specification that you
learned is a useful one
and we get this pink one so it is
already pretty much better than the
black one
and if you use a formula that is
inferred by using a different uh
criterion we get this blue one
and then if you warm start by using the
underlying policy from the source task
source environments uh the underlying
policies then we obtain the
red one so uh what we see here is that
um yeah we can we can expedite the
learning in the
target environment if we just try to do
what i described
um and a couple of things
these uh red one pink one and blue one
for the if we could look at it carefully
they don't
uh there is no movements here for the
first 10 000 steps
that's the data that they use to figure
out whether there is a logical
similarity or not
there is no rl reinforcement learning
happening in that
in that window the the black one has
these vehicles here because
it starts to see things sooner
and then after waiting for that
amount of uh samples um
the red pink and blue one uh actually go
up
pretty quickly um so
this is this is a step toward if there
are
if there is knowledge that we can try to
discover or we can't
we have a priory uh that uh you can
incorporate it in that
reinforcement learning and make things
make things
more efficient and
the other side of which before i take a
break the other side is this inverse
reinforcement learning
and um and i i i have to say a few words
so that
you can what to discuss with anna is
going to make a little bit of sense
uh so the inverse reinforcement learning
is
a little bit different it is used for uh
several
purposes so let's say we have an
environment
somebody took our robot or whatever and
it started showing us these
what's called demonstrations the person
drives the system
in this way and it takes another
it does another demonstration i don't
know what similar but different
okay um so we have certain number of
demonstrations in that
and now with this enviro demonstrations
given the underlying model of the system
given
we try to come up with a reward function
that's going to
when we optimize with respect to that
reward function is going to generate a
policy
that mimics the demonstrations you come
up with a reward function
that gives you a policy take that policy
run in the system
you will see behavior that is similar in
some sense to these demonstrations that
we have
started from so that's inverse
reinforcement learning
and specifications in this case come
into play
as not as site information and
site information is the following so let
me just give you this example first if
this is a driving example
the demonstrations may be how a
particular driver drives
side information may be the traffic
rules in a sane world
every driver follows the traffic rules
so we don't have to
re learn them from scratch
in this little example in addition to
these demonstrations these say
you always start from this blue thing
you always
you avoid these red things and you go to
the green things
in these orders in this order first this
one and this one and then eventually
just you end up being in the yellow
region i believe
these specifications say that
and then we want to generate a reward
function
that not only mimics the demonstrations
but also tries to
improve us somewhat maximize the
probability of satisfying this these the
specifications that we started
so um that's the problem statement and
uh the so let me skip how we solve this
but essentially
uh the
the um the solution
just one solution to this is it builds
on the
uh so-called uh maximum likelihood
inverse reinforcement learning some
parameterization of the rewards
and then from that await a specific way
to go to a policy
and then the cost function is trying to
make
to choose the theta corresponding to the
policy pi
sub theta in such a way that the
behavior is similar to the
demonstrations
when the policy is implemented on your
markup decision process
uh and then instead of uh running the
inverse reinforcement learning over the
mvp
we run it over the product space uh over
the product mdp
and we keep track of the possibility of
violating the specifications
and penalize the violation probability
in this thing so that
the methods behind maximum entropy
inverse reinforcement learning can be
used to solve this problem
or try to solve this problem
here's an example without site
information and with side information
it is the same map that i have been
showing and blue means
low probability of satisfying the
specifications and yellow means probable
to one
if we don't incorporate site information
uh
and the the colors are if if i start
from this shown cell what is my
likelihood of satisfying the
specifications
and there are lots of blue regions
on the other hand uh every cell has
almost red uh colored almost
sure satisfaction of the uh the
specifications regardless of where you
start from unless you start from
uh from these red places already because
you would have violated the safety
the specification already if you started
from those
and why do we have it i think the
explanation is pretty easy
if you look at this picture in these
regions
we don't have any demonstrations there's
no data whatsoever
and if we go to this picture
these areas where we don't have data is
bluer than
where we have data so specifications
help us
actually uh generalize to respect the
satisfaction of specifications
over the places where we had not seen
any data
and is this at the expense of being nuts
similar to the demonstrations that were
given to us
these figures essentially try to uh
explain that
at least in this example you know we
satisfy the specifications and the
behavior that we generate
is still quite similar to the
demonstrations
if you have seen demonstrations in these
areas and if you start in these areas
you will be like them but you will still
satisfy the specifications if you start
at other places
but this is not changing the environment
if you change the environment even a
tiny bit
uh if take this one and put it here
uh things things break so
maybe ideas of the previous type hey the
environment change now
can i figure these things out with less
complications less data but
yeah those are not fun games
i don't see that much of interesting
research somebody needs to do it
okay let's take a break
okay uh let's uh continue at
49 whatever is your time zone is that
okay
okay then let's continue in five minutes
foreign how are we
okay it looks that everybody's bakufuk
are you ready for another round or
you had enough of us in our questions
no i have not have enough questions
please have more questions and i'm ready
okay so oh someone has more please
whoever has more please
shoot uh and it's you please yeah yeah i
have more
so i was wondering in this uh logic
logic learning when you learn logical
similarities
so this is really nice approach because
it guides this exploration and it's
really cool
uh how important is the mi
in mitl there so is this what's guiding
the exploration
uh so the mi part is
it is it is cheating logic right you you
have these
numbers so that you can write mixed
integer linear programming
problems that you can study optimization
throughout just the
appropriate optimization methods that
you can use it right
and that is what the per person who
actually worked on this was familiar
um later on we tried to look into with
daniel neider from mpi in
slaughtering and a couple of others
uh not necessarily doing it milp it was
just sort of what is it
metric internal temporal logic but uh
more discrete
uh just sheer discrete logic um
and and it seems to help in a similar
manner
there has been work um
on both
if you know something have to
incorporate it so that you make the
learning
faster there's no target or anything but
then also
uh there are quite a bit of uh extension
on
not necessarily doing it early on and
then using that
uh first infer and then learn
uh so daniel obviously had been working
on
automata learning uh so there is a joint
automaton learning and reinforcement
learning they run in parallel
and you you have a loop uh you you have
you you obviously uh every time you
get something new through automaton
learning your automation changes they
try to
they incorporate it into reinforcement
learning and similar actually better
improvements are possible so that is not
dedicated to that i think this idea of
using some sort of logic to encapsulate
knowledge which is algorithmically
actionable
and incorporating that into learning is
it has the very different flavors that
that is pretty universal then the
question is
um can i develop algorithms on that
whether my learning algorithm will be
able to take advantage of whether i can
actually run the learning algorithm with
that
knowledge incorporated now
there are there are lots of different
levels of questions that you can ask
and i think it is wide open still and i
am very much pissed at myself that
that the environment changes even a tiny
bit things do not work
i think that might give a nice
discussion for for the rest of the
semester i i feel like we are not taking
advantage of knowledge sufficiently
yeah yeah so i would be happy to also
discuss this
ah yeah sure okay i will be happy uh so
the last piece harmony piece um
and why palm dps because why not
uh it is just everything is a partially
observable
but we just pretend that it is not now
let's put it in
uh and um so
the approaches that i'm gonna show here
are how can
uh how can we cheat but get somewhat
useful solutions
because um
this is hard right synthesis and public
is in every form it's hard
there is no i i think we touched on this
yesterday we must have
um and um
so restriction to finite memory
strategies so in general you might need
infinite memory restrictions to find out
memory strategies
may give you a working environment
yet still hard and it's going to induce
sub-optimality so
randomization might come in as
randomized policies might give you a
little bit more
without having to use extensive
memory so these are the type of thoughts
that had been going into
what i'm going to discuss today
question yeah
okay so
um all right good so let's let's move on
i thought there was a question but
there's nothing
uh so this is the type of thoughts that
will go and uh
and then i'll first try to make a
connection between formal methods and
some sort of convex optimization
um and then i said palm dps but
i will not talk about pomdps i'm going
to talk about a related problem i'm
going to talk about
synthesis in uh parametric markov
sorry parametric mdps parametric
mdps mdps
and markov chains okay and the reason is
comes from uh
i don't know if others had made it but
uh
to to my uh i guess knowledge it comes
through
the work by uh people around you spiller
cartoon and
becker and the realization is that
if you take all finite state controllers
implemented on mdp uh with some
bounded fixed memory can be represented
as a parametric markov chain
so uh and then uh i'm gonna get into
parametric
mark this micro decision processes in
the next slide markov chain is
yes it is what it implies that you take
a policy and you induce a parametric
markov chain
uh so um
and then there is a correspondence
between a strategy finite state strategy
uh for a uh for a palm dp and the
parameter instantiations
in this in this parametric markov chain
so we'll try to
leverage this this corresponds so for
now let me now go
to uh parametric mdps
uh so it is a mdp markov decision
process
but the um the transition probabilities
are not specified and they are
parameters
in this case p1 and obviously this one
is going to mine one minus b1
this one this probability here is p1
squared
uh this picture is probably missing
something because
if p1 is not one something is missing
there anyway
uh so the long story short is instead of
having numbers specified numbers
we have parameters that had not been
specified
and then we will try to throw in some
specifications
maybe the probability of uh reaching a
target set
is uh less than something or
ever going to some some undesired place
the probability is smaller than
something
and and some performance specification
in the expected cost
form these are these are not necessarily
what they mean
let me put these in quotes so this is a
this is some sort of performance
specification and this is some
safe specification then the question
that
we will look into is there's an
objective function whatever that is
some f from the parameters to reals
so the question is given in parametric
markov decision process
and find an instantiation of the
parameters
these guys along with a scheduler
strategy over this mdp such that once
you put the
the parameter values that these these
things
and then the schedulers you end up
having a markov chain
you want to satisfy the specifications
and while you are doing it
why not optimize some some other some
other objective function over the
parameters that you want
and the objective functions maybe
i know if this is this could be modeling
a model repair problem
i have my probabilities but i want to
change the probabilities in some way so
i might have introduced some parameters
so repair it in such a way that the
change from the nominal values is small
that might be a metric but you can you
can come up with all sorts of other
things
so this is just a problem statement
and here's a solution so it's this is a
solution essentially
nothing much different you just follow
the
what you would do for um perhaps
for solving a uh a policy synthesis
problem for a market decision process
but obviously we have many more pieces
to it
so we'll crack we will in addition to
the parameters in the problem
which will appear in this transition
probable matrix here the
parameters are there we have these extra
variables
to keep track of the the random
scheduler that we will be
looking for and the ps will be the
probability of reaching this t
from the set t from uh from
from state s and then at the x
the expected cost of reaching g this
other thing that
that we used in the performance
criterion is going to be kept track of
us
c sub s uh
essentially there are like the parts of
the problem is this is the objective
function
uh these are bounds on the uh
on the probability from the initial
state so from from where i start i
respect the
constraints that i have and then the
rest is that you have a valid defined
scheduler and parameter instantiation
and then uh the the you keep track of
the
recursively you keep track of the uh
whether the safety specifications are
going what the what the probability of
satisfying safety specifications will be
and what the expected cost is going to
be again recursively from
uh from where you are
so this is not surprising because we had
seen lots of optimization problems
in in similar form what is going on here
is
probably i'm gonna focus on this one bit
here
so uh and i copied in the next page so
what is going on
there is nothing goofy here but what
happens is this is this
includes decision variables this
includes decision variables
and this has the parameters in it and
the parameters themselves may
actually be even nonlinear functions of
the para
the the the entries of this p may be
non-linear functions of of the
parameters
so it because of
these kinds of complications the problem
had been regarded as
a just a nominal programming problem and
then you would solve it as a non-linear
program
but uh there is quite a bit of structure
in this in this form
uh so what happens is that actually uh
it is in the form of if if the if these
are polynomially dependent or fine
dependents
this entire thing is going to be in the
in this form
okay that entire so there's going to be
a coefficient
and the variables raised to certain
powers then you
you multiply them so some monomials in
terms of the variables that we have
and some coefficients it is that
structure
it is nonlinear but it has that stretch
um and then a little bit of a
terminology
if this coefficient is uh strictly
positive
this kind of function called is called
polynomial and then if there's no
restriction on the
coefficients it is going to be called a
signometer
so the question is whether we can
exploit the structure or mass all right
and it turns out that not necessarily
directly but
through some approximation you may be
able to so this is the problem that we
start from
and then uh we restrict
our attention to uh parametric mdps with
signomela synonymous everywhere
non-linearities are signals let's go
back
uh so we will work with signomils uh
in this form all these nonlinearities
will appear in this form
and then that problem itself is not
necessarily
uh anything nice that still leads this
nonlinear program but then there is a
very much related problem which is a
geometric programming problem and it
restricts the attention to polynomials
in the in the cost function and uh
in the in the inequality constraint
and the equality constraints these can
only be monomials
so there is no summation just mono uh if
i go back
again the equal to constraints can only
have one of these things
it cannot have a bunch of multiplication
and then summation it cannot have that
uh so if the problem was in this form
which is not because
uh we have signomeols instead of
polynomials
geometric programming problems are
actually can be solved as convex
optimization problems
so we may be able to solve that a little
bit more efficiently at least from where
i come from
when i hear the convex optimization as a
term and i say okay okay
the life is nice but life is not nice
yet
and then we can solve this generation
programming problem and obtain a
physical solution for the crown that we
were dealing with so i'm going to show
you a couple of tricks
or restrictions that is going to
bring us to a geometric programming form
so first of all this is the one of the
troublemaking terms what's going to
happen is instead of this equality
we will relax this thing to an
inequality
so it's going to show itself here
and then the rest is just trivial we
will assume that this p of s p
p sub s is not zero and divided by that
that's that's the only part
so essentially this relaxes the equality
constraint to an equal inequality
constraint and
because of this relaxation we will not
get the exact probability values that we
are looking for but we will get upper
bounds on them
and then then we end up having
something in this form so how are we
going to deal with this
it turns out that all but one of these
entries
is a polynomial and
uh this extra one is a signal so the
signal part is the the complicating part
is
only in one of these terms the the the
other depends on the parameters
what we will do is uh again
when when i face something hard i just
close my eyes and say i'm going to get
rid of that all right we will introduce
a new variable and this is going to be
the lifting part so we will have
additional variables now and we will
close our eyes that
this is uh this is a synonym for now
so with all those restrictions we can go
back
and obtain a geometric programming
problem
uh geometric program and we can try to
solve it
and since we had all these liftings and
relaxations etc some sort of
regularization
we add that to this problem statements
so the
rest is as i explained and then we
regularize it
uh so that the in this
in this modified decision space
we try to get solutions that would
probably be getting a bit closer to the
solutions that
we would get without uh without easy
relaxations
for the problem that we would not be
able to solve effect efficiently
so if you if you wonder i can't say that
this is
total hack uh don't tell to the student
uh so um but it's a total hack that
seems to
help so then the point is that the
solution to this
gives essentially a feasible solution
for the problem that we wanted
but it can be sub-optimal all right
uh and then the next step is
okay now we have a way of creating
feasible solutions can improve it
the next step is so-called sequential
convex programming essentially you have
a solution around that you
linearize you get another solution fix
that as your current
solution linearize around that do it
again and again and again
okay uh no no step solves and
hopeless problem at least what happens
is that
it works so
for some benchmarks uh z3
offered an encoding that we could use
for this initial uh
initial set of results uh in many cases
uh in many benchmarks i think somehow
uh it was either not applicable or uh
something was there that we could not
try it okay
and then this one is this this
hack uh and
what happens is that um
for example here the z3 based
solution times out and uh this
sequential comics programming based
technique
generates some solutions and then
i guess there is no case where this this
method is worse than
uh worse than uh what z3 could do on the
problems that it can solve
for example here um about two orders of
magnitude
or a little bit more better computation
time
and the relatively large markov decision
processes
the number of parameters are uh are
still
pretty low uh but then
similar ideas a different
uh optimization solver under underlying
different types of relaxations
uh could go much farther
so essentially
what i showed was that things were
scaling relatively well for the number
of transitions and states
but now they are also scaling relatively
well
for the number of parameters that was
the sticking point
in the entire uh parametric markov
decision process synthesis problems
because they created non-linearities
from being able to handle two three
parameters
uh this way of trying to have a
sequential convex optimization uh way of
approaching this
goes to thousands of parameters and
um so these are this is this this this
is working
relatively nice and then
whether these numbers mean anything uh
let me look at show you one example
where actually it did something
okay uh so this is this is a little
example
where we have a satellite and some sort
of discretization
informed by the physics of it this is
not you take a 3d space and try to
discretize it in the way that i
said but it goes and finds some
orbits that satisfy the underlying uh
underlying physics of the problem
and then solves the uh discrete problem
uh with respect to
these orbits and the discrete states are
which orbit i am on and where on that
orbit i am at and then there are these
other objects around it that it probably
tries to not crash
etc and tries to use least amount of
fuel
and this is not even a problem with a
pond dp
we also introduced uncertainties in the
pmdp that the transition probabilities
are not exactly known
so it is trying to solve a pomdp
synthesis problem
but robustify against the transition
probabilities as well
the uncertainties in the transition
probabilities and
uh and and this is pretty sizable
problem i i don't remember exact number
of
uh states or uh and parameters but my
the number of states are getting to half
a million states perhaps and the
parameters are uh essentially sufficient
number of parameters that it can handle
uh so that it can come up with a policy
for this
uh pmdp if you remember the
the correspondence between the the
parameters in a in a markov chain and
the
the uh the controller's term the
controller for
for the underlying palmdp and
it follows roughly the similar
just the flaw you have a problem on
certain market decision process
and um and a specification
straightforward formulation gives a
semi-infinite
infinitely many constraints so-called
quadratic constraint quadratic program
and a non-convex one actually
so um and then convexify it
uh somehow pass it to with no loss
pass it to a finite representation of
the uncertain set
uh solve the resulting problem if it's
satisfied you are fine if it is not
satisfied
you inform the solution and you go on
so this way of uh convexifying the
underlying
nasty problems for
finding feasible solutions for
synthesising
partially observable market decision
processes and then
improving the solutions uh with
help from model checking probabilistic
model checking
is it seems like it is a i like it
so then there is no end to it
what i showed was one way of
convexifying and dealing with it and
making a finite problem out of it and
then improving
but then you can linearize the problem
then go to do dual
representation of those problems and
then solve it's different thing and it
also works
actually it works better i just was lazy
to create this slide for this person
and i just put that banner there we can
discuss them
later uh so this connection between
convex optimization
and the type of problems that we
actually try to deal with in
informal methods or probabilistic
versions of these i think is a very
promising
uh direction
the last bit i'll try to make this short
the next last bit is still palm dp
and i'm going to try to show you how
formal methods and learning
might work together all right for this
purpose
uh so they did and i am borrowing some
slides from niels jensen for us
uh nils did not know it but thank you
niels if you ever watch this
uh so we are we have a pump dp and we
have some specifications
some problems that come from logic
constraints let's say synthesis is hard
so if someone gave me a strategy i can
check it the strategy here is
a observation based strategy it looks at
finite history
and tries to make a decision out of it
you take that
implement it onto palmdp you end up
having a markov chain
verifying whether a markov chain
satisfies something is
let's call it the ease of problem okay
we'll treat that as the ease of problem
here
then the question is whether it is
satisfies or not it satisfies we are
done if it doesn't satisfy we are not
done
what what are we going to do in that
case and the next question is
who who's going to give me a strategy
that i can check like this
okay so this was so i'm going to first
address this who's going to give me the
strategy part
and so it never happened in this way
around the table but could ai give us
this right
again i said ai is capable of predicting
men will die
i know when i'm gonna die by the way i
use that box and it told me
uh so this is a great question
but then there are also these cartoons
that's what
we think that ai can do and what the ai
can do
actually uh ai is gonna just sorry i
should stop using ai
uh can we learn a strategy as a
as a like a good can we learn strategy
that would be a candidate for that
procedure
even if you learned it is very unlikely
that it's going to satisfy the
specifications that we have
we have in mind okay but can we use
something like that as an initial step
so uh this is a um
an ugly figure
but the point is that learn something
and then improve it
with help from verification uh
we have upon dp a specification an
initial policy
and then in this flow we will keep track
of
a policy as well so gamma hat is the
policy that we have
and it is represented as
something a recurrent neural network
okay don't ask me what it is
it is something okay it takes your
finite observation sequences and it
spits out a distribution
over your actions right just the
observation based
randomized policy sense and
it has a fancy name but why why is it
why is it used i can answer that
it is used just because it
gives a representation of a policy
that as data comes in
you can revise efficiently
by using the so-called whatever the deep
reinforcement learning algorithms do
right so that is that is the only reason
it is it is a
if it is a representation that is going
to consume your data
efficiently nothing else all right
to me nothing else and then
we can we have now a candidate policy
but we cannot model we cannot take that
and put on a
on a palm dp and model check that we
need something that is going to be a
finite
it has a finite state representation
so a lot of hack oh by the way every
step of this thing is a
total heck but it is going to hurt okay
so um you you
you go and uh quantize
the underlying um whatever is continuous
and then look at the what the um
this recurrent neural network based
controller does
fix a memory structure for your finite
state controller
there there is a literature on that
increasing literature on that
out there but you get a
finite state controller now for for
out of your recurrent neural network
based controller
why didn't what why did you why did this
not start with this already
go back to why was why we are we decided
to use recurrent neural networks
i don't think there is a way to train a
controller of this form
efficiently from data so you you
try to efficiently train something
extract
an approximation of that when i say
approximation it needs to be
like between 17 codes because there's no
sense of
like what is the bound on the
approximation error here
to try to do that once you have it then
you can model check it
right again if it passes fine um
very likely it is not going to pass so
if it doesn't pass
what might have gone wrong uh a couple
of things
one that your problem was not sold
if that's the case you can just you
wouldn't know that
the other sources your recurring neural
network was not doing its job properly
maybe you can then uh create some more
data and
try to improve that or your extraction
of the finite state controller was not
fine enough
the network was fine but your finite
state controller is not fine
you can try to add more memory and you
can try to improve your approximation of
this finite state approximation up to
the current network
so a bunch of hacks again going to this
f hack things try to make a decision
whether i should generate more data
or whether i should try to refine my
approximation of the existing
recurrent neural network and then you
close the loop and you go
okay and then this last thing shows
i don't know how to erase all this stuff
now here um
let me let me give a shot at this if it
erases things
okay it did so what is that from
iteration iteration
the probability of satisfying the
specification improves
this is this this shows that and
this shows essentially
that the problem making parts of
the what we have is shrinking in size
okay and then this one shows with a
fixed amount of memory it shows as we
put more data this ad
hoc metric that we use to decide whether
we should
increase the memory for the finite state
controller or we should
try to generate more data and refine the
recurrent neural network
if this thing called this average
entropy
of something that the algorithm
generates
decreases that's a sign that you cannot
do
any much better by incorporating more
data you better actually now
increase the memory that you use for
your finite state controls
so these graphs are in the in the right
directions
and and what we have
so what we have is that this is
essentially gives
a if it works it gives a correct
strategy
but uh it may actually fail you in
finding a feasible strategy for your
specifications so it is definitely not
your problem might be solvable but it is
not necessarily going to give you
a a solution not surprising
and then a good number of um a good
number of
comparison on a bunch of small
and increasing the large palm dps here
uh this is the state space and then uh
compared to prism palmdp
um i don't know if it is always the case
but the computation time is
uh it is better it can it can
um it can scale up significantly more
than uh prison pump dp
but again it is not going to get you the
like the
optimal solution and it is worth
actually checking whether
it is getting ridiculously far away
results uh and
uh so as for comparison uh this is when
it can solve
all these smaller problems what prism
mdp gets and what this
uh this procedure with the learning and
formal verification incorporated gets it
is in the ballpark
uh it is it is almost never better but
six versus six point o two eight versus
eight point eleven obviously it depends
on the problem that we are solving
it is in the ballpark and it can scale
up uh
significantly uh more than uh what
prison
on dp does more examples
i'm gonna i'm gonna just show you just
the point of it is it works this is the
last slide
okay i can do it in three minutes maybe
not so this is where i started from
there are lots of complications
for autonomy and i try to show you a few
examples where actually
just the this group including hopefully
as the fly on the wall includes me can
actually go and
see what we can how we can do things
with and
merge ideas with different directions
and solve
increasingly interesting problems so
i'm not going to say more on this thing
what i'm going to try to tell you is
that
the sky is the limit for this way of
thinking i believe so recently we ran
this
series of workshops on where or what
like
what is next for autonomy and
essentially we believe that individual
systems are coming along well
uh and so we now need to start thinking
about how we can limit these things
in a way that we can trust and then the
this is a workshop report
uh and it it discusses the complications
or opportunities challenges in these
seven or nine
uh bullet points or the titles
and some of the common comments were i
think worth remembering and i think
aligned with what we discussed today
so what is that do we even have to care
about assurance
in autonomous systems and
no assurance i think in this case
include is
equal to no useful autonomy we cannot
think about autonomous systems with
appropriate assurance on what they will
do then
autonomous systems like they inherit
diverse set of vulnerabilities because
they
integrate functionality from different
places hence
i think our methods needs to be aligned
with that
aligned with that and then in almost
every subtitle people had
acknowledged and these are not by the
way this is this is not group of
former methods people sitting down and
trying to write
a report that says hey formal methods is
important it is
i'm not sure if we had we had some forum
about this people but
it wasn't more than like five to ten
percent of the of the group of people
uh open everybody acknowledges that we
work in an open world and that
complicates a lot of things
and then we need interdisciplinary
approaches and it should not be an
afterthought
if you're going to speak with all these
people who had who are experts in
business
what they will say is that hey this is
very important but we cannot deal with
this after we build a system
this needs to be this needs to come as
the beginning of
at the beginning and i'm going to
comment a little bit on what what that
might mean
but to me the message there is you
cannot
incorporate any of these thoughts if you
don't properly formalize them
at the beginning and guess what
formal methods has the word formal in it
and formalize has the word formal in it
right
uh and i am this is this is not a
superficial comment i am just making
here to make us happy
i truly believe in this because
in a lot of these things there is no
shortage of
probably ideas what i think the shortage
is where the self-discipline and and
formal methods can bring that
self-discipline
just let at least you can say even if
you fail in it you can say
let me sit down and write the damn thing
that i want to do
give me a problem statement if you can't
give me a problem statement
who cares about your solution you know
what that obvious statement
is not that common out there you should
go and teach your neighbor and we
usually discuss safety and verification
what i realized was secure obvious
security is extremely important
and i don't know if marshall is here or
not we are making backward progress in
security
uh so uh just there's a lot of problems
that we can try to
we can try to look into it and then it
gets broader certification and
regulation how can how can we do this
damn thing so that
we can we can inform how the regulations
need to be written how
whether the regulation should be how we
can write the regulation so that
there's a little bit of a hope actually
doing these things in an automated
manner or we can scale these things up
or not
there's so much interesting work out
there that
even the written regulations do not have
any meaning and they might even be
inconsistent with each other
the tiniest the the zeroth order problem
that we can try to solve should be able
to actually
inform that process privacy is
everybody is saying privacy privacy
privacy but
very little few people understand not
that i understand it
uh i'm not criticizing the others i'm
just saying that i understand it
but here's a little example that i think
gives very interesting challenges for
for
formal methods you have a some sort of a
system
it consumes data you and there's the
differential privacy
world out there that formalizes some
sort of privacy not that it is the
perfect
like most meaningful privacy notion but
there is a
mathematical based notion of privacy out
there differential privacy
it goes and introduces bunch of new
noise into your system
how can you go and verify that this new
noise is not going to cause any safety
vulnerabilities can you come up with
trade-offs between the amount of privacy
hence noise that you introduce your
system
and that the safety implications of that
the list goes on pretty neatly i suggest
that you take a look if you like and
then i'm happy to discuss
but i feel like every paragraph is full
of problems for us
okay this is a great time to be running
this semester and
thank you the organizers whoever had
come up with this idea
this is the end of my talk okay great
thank you very much let's first
give some virtual thank you for our
speaker
and uh are just some questions that uh
you would like to
ask that i mean we had a bunch of
questions through the discussion but
maybe if they're somehow please either
raise hand or put them in the chat
while we are waiting for people maybe i
can ask where is this
report available is it the publicly
available authority
or uh i can post the
link but if you google ccc i should
autonomy
okay that's good so that's good you know
google this is
a shirt
and indeed i see it thank you
so uh maybe you can ask one question uh
that goes back when you uh now kind of
already start to
uh like a little bit when you were
comparing uh your tool
mo mottas mataseka was it the name
mosaic is a
uh a convex optimization software
right yeah right so uh
if you look at the that tool uh what was
um
i mean you i can see that it was much it
was much
uh faster than the c3 and well it uh
what was the secret ingredient i mean i
remember that uh you
inserted that you change this inequal
equalities to inequalities and that you
argue
why you can do that and uh did you
uh was it that because it was trying to
solve this as a linear integer
arithmetic problem or what was the
such a great trade-off in the
optimism in the scalability
i will come back to you okay
sure uh i i don't know okay
sure no problem i
i'm looking forward to hear what was it
because that's really impressive uh
improvement
i cannot think of what what what was
passed to z3 but
i will get back to you no not sure
uh let's see more questions
so yeah that's there's no questions then
oh no sorry right now raise hands
please right now yeah i have a somewhat
speculative question
related to that so kind of the like the
the final success stories that you
showed us it was
kind of something which uh like which
you called hack which is essentially
i mean i wouldn't call it i guess it's
engineering
and then on top of that you have like in
order to get the guarantees on top of
that
you apply a like a formal methods tool
and and then you get uh some kind of you
know safety guarantees and maybe
sacrificing performance
but so do you think that that's the end
of that that should be the way that we
should
kind of be thinking forward right how to
like
or like is there like more scope for
bringing kind of the
like the two worlds closer together in
terms of
trying to develop methods that uh that
are
uh and not hacks from the beginning but
kind of more principled in terms of
development i am in
no position to say what we should be
doing
what i can say is that
this is one one thing that one group of
people has done and
tried and got results it would be
how much this was with others if you can
bring people together and try to develop
dedicated
tools that are less engineering more
more principles i don't disagree with
that at all
and i think
um i mean the question was whether one
can do better than that i mean maybe
it's it's not really possible really
or easily solvable to uh
yeah one thing that is a little bit
clearer just to
so that we have a discussion what
whether
there is going to be a principled thing
a less hack in some way or less
engineering
let's remember that there's a reason
for us we had gone this
route we know that there is not going to
be a
efficient solution to these problems
uh right um
so um in my mind
this way of thinking should never be the
first
thing that you do if you face a new
problem
um at least understand the complexity of
the problem first
maybe the specific problem that you are
trying to solve is not as hard as what
is known out there try to come up with a
precise complex
description if you are convinced that
now
a principled way is hopeless
which is uh just you
you prove it not just you you have a
hunch for it
then i think it is fair game try these
i have a similar discussion with my
students often
on whether you should just abandon what
we are doing
and train neural networks
all right uh and
uh as a conscious advisor i cannot tell
them not to use neural networks
but what i tell them is go and
i tell them what i just told you go and
prove me that the specific problem that
you are trying to solve
sorry is heart
hopelessly hard then you do whatever
hack you want to
do so i think this this this should be
hand to hands
and again just putting discipline on you
and this process might even tell you
how to modify your problem so that you
might come up with a subset of the
problem that you did not need the more
general thing that you can have a more
efficient solar etc
yeah i i am i am in no position to tell
people what to do
don't give up on any of the
possibilities limit your use of
things that you don't understand
thanks yep
okay so i guess we even we even you
promised it will be done way before the
time and look at us you had such give
such a good talk that we've run back
over well
looks a little bit over time so uh thank
you very much ufo
and uh let's stop here and i mean we
still have whole semester that we will
be able to discuss this interesting
uh topics oh no amy you do you have a
quick question or
uh is it long if it's long then you will
have to ask off offline
remy or
that's uh is it no that's not racecam
sorry
okay then let's stop here and uh thank
you very much and
have a good weekend and see you soon
bye everyone bye bye